[Music]
brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or braks or
whatever to help the people in Gaza but
then just imagine this amazing de that
you want to do but we turn it into into
a moneymaking machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inah I've
got two amazing Brothers here on my
right mam on my left thean the champ the
one and only of course yes um you know
he's one of the best da Channels with
comedy and da and it's a unique mix he's
done here it's very it's a very unique
blend it is it is of
artistic um Talent okay that is is it
mixes um you know substance yeah with
style that's right in a way that in a
way that uh people don't know how to do
and and what about Z
know you guys going to M to that till
the day of judgment you can use that me
okay guys so uh today in we're going to
be reacting in it's a video sent me
right yeah yeah so you guys know what
the attack that took place in attack it
was
it it was and Subhan Allah we don't even
know who these people are because it's
so bizarre like the the the what they
did and when they got caught I mean you
see these individuals who are really
messed up in the I have to say I saw
some of the videos and I was actually I
was actually surprised that the Russians
didn't do more I know that I know that
sounds quite harsh thing to say there
was a there was a point where that these
guys were actually in hospitals like I
saw them in the hospital bed BR bro 100%
I believe there wor should be done I
don't even know if I'm legally allowed
cut one by one step by stepo I
was I'll be honest any I cut that out
but no because I I thought the Russ
would do more um but obviously cutting
their ear and stuff is uh they gave they
made put in his allegedly allegedly well
he did cut the allegedly I mean there
Clips in it the real question
everybody's wondering well Russia
doesn't get a an opportunity to get the
story is banned in it really by the way
Hamas and the Taliban have actually I
think condemned this in on certain terms
interesting and you know what people
really want to know is you know
everything that's going on Israel they
really want to know if Ali condemns
Hamas yeah condemn anyone that don't
pray namas but the point is this yeah
it's just a bizarre attack is this
really Isis and this very Isis that for
odd reason attacks everyone and kills
Muslims but for some odd reason just
does not say or do anything against
Israel very bizarre and what's
interesting is they the W group that
apologizes to Israel as well because in
the Golden Heights who who apologize
what why yeah Isis apologized to Israel
for killing someone the people in the go
youing are you making this up oh no no
I'll give you the evidence brother bring
you evidence if you're truthful I'm
going to give you the evidence I don't
know if I'm truthful though evidence you
tell the story about how you tried to
find out what the what they call the mad
when they deal with publicly I thought
it was a reasonable question but the
trouble is uh you can't pick up the
phone book there's no Langley in in
Israel that you can look up you know CIA
or in our case the mosad we thought we
should ask what shall we call it in
English you can translate the Hebrew
word as I said mada's Institute but when
they write a letter to their friends in
the CIA or the British intelligence
whatever they call themselves it took a
while uh it was a matter of asking the
Prime Minister spokesman the best you
could do because officially uh the mosad
is under the prime minister's office and
uh I think he sort of wondered why you
want to know and all that so we
explained and he came up with u the
Israeli secret intelligence service I if
it were to have initials it would be IIs
s just simple words like that
interestingly enough a kind of a British
and but you're you're saying that maybe
it's it's not Isis I mean what evidence
do you have Ali let's watch and
[Music]
see I don't understand this language
brother false
flag
[Music]
for
that's
fine
you guys get the
idea okay guys so we saw that Subhan
Allah now is that a surprise to you is
that like for her to say that I'll be
honest with even before it happened I
was like really to to be honest um false
flag attacks like this are very common
in history anyone who's a student of
geopolitics they know even in Cuba um
there's been Declassified documents of
the US um saying that they would blow up
a ship and blame the Cubans just so uh
this war would happen or just so you
know the Americans would be on side and
this has happened many times even
Israelis have have committed false flag
attacks as well to get the British on
side before they can do it again like
there there are definite precedents in
place that they have not only occurred
uh they are in established documented
Declassified documents in fact so when
Russia is saying it they're not saying
it just out of nowhere out of thin air
because Russia is is definitely in
center stage in fact China is getting
roped into it as well it's actually
becoming East versus West that's how
it's becoming so is it any wonder that
something like this would would be
taking place at A Moment Like This even
when there's a clip on RT where there's
an Israeli saying we're going to come
for you we know what you've done because
let me tell you we're going to finish
this war we're going to win because
we're stronger after this Russia will
pay the price believe me Russia will
Russia the the price Russia is
supporting the enemies of Israel Russia
is supporting Nazi people who want to
commit genocide on us and just Russia
will pay the price because there there
is uh also people saying that Russia was
and is assisting um what's going on the
resistance in Palestine as well yeah so
Russia is definitely kind of seen not to
be favorable um to the West at this
moment in time and even possibly Israel
as well 100% the Z have their hands
everywhere so I won be surprised they
what you make out well don't say that
don't say that I think that was actually
a fantastic analysis by Zan and um it's
it's actually a very plausible one
because if you consider where Russia is
on the on the map um geopolitically it
really is a difference between you know
what could happen in the future because
it's one of the only powers that if a
mus or conglomerate of Muslim countries
had its backing could change the
situation in the world in terms of
Palestine
so I I think that Russia is the key in
fact it's one of the only countries in
the world that can stand up to the
United States of America so one of the
only countries the other other
alternative is is China but uh you've
got two two options Russia at this
moment in time is at war with um
effectively at war with NATO so I mean
it's not really at with NATO if you like
now but yeah you know it's a proy war
it's it's more significant than many of
the proxy wars that took place in the
Cold War in fact yeah um so I do think
that this there's all the incentive and
the motive in the world for this to have
come somewhere from the west or from
Israel itself and and not only that bro
if you look at the four individuals that
carried this um this disgusting attack
is that one thing you notice with these
people even in history like the prophet
PE upon at the time Kar existed because
these people are like Kar by the way we
don't know who the these P individuals
are this extreme group of Muslim we
don't deny their them being a Muslim or
not I know there are some Scholars these
guys could just be mercenaries they can
be but the point is this you've noticed
something the ones who killed Ali that
some some narration say that when he was
being the sahaba were basically chopping
the limb by limb and he did not flinch
the moment they come to cut his tongue
off he started crying and they said to
him why are you crying now he said I
want to do the of Allah before I die
they are in this false reality of
thinking they're doing it now these four
individuals and one thing you I attacks
they Carri attacks until they get they
killed or they killed theel yeah with
these guys they run they caught and they
crying and I'm thinking to myself I know
how crazy brain
these Isis individuals can be yeah so to
see that I was like that doesn't that
doesn't look like do you get it when
when they are immersed that's an
interesting point as well because Thea
the traits of of Isis versus them have
you seen video the language that they
they're saying it doesn't add up and the
the way they're behaving cuz I saw a
video them being chased in the forest
and he's crying I'm like bro you just
went how did you go from zero
to
so it shows me there's something else
going on yeah think that's actually a
very good point cuz when I was looking
at those videos it doesn't seem like
we're all privy to um Isis videos like
I'm not sure if you guys were watching
it but the Vice news used to bring them
out all the time we kind of know what
the traits of an Isis fighter isct like
what kind of language they would use
what kind of Pence they would have what
kind of attitud they want to die yeah
exactly so it's a lot of it is this
prideful almost uh yeah braggadocious
kind of style this these guys don't have
any of that and so it seemed like they
were just kind of paid mercenary exactly
and they had weapons on them they could
have fired back at the Russian military
they don't they get caught without being
injured not being shot none of them was
shot yes oh it doesn't none of them was
shot they got caught and obviously they
got tortured but it's bizarre to me it's
like you know what bro 100% there is
definitely someone else involved to
change convenient timing isn't it yeah
bro even um even Putin as well he took a
more diplomatic approach but even his
diplomacy you can read between the lines
and see what he's saying as well Putin
said that okay these were islamist
attacks however he's saying we want to
find out the state sponsors Behind These
individuals so again he's in in
different words saying this why would
any Muslim country want to attack Russia
let's just ask question for what reason
would any Muslim country or anyone who's
behind stateb whatever for what reason
yes it might be that the whole situation
Syria it might be a connection of maybe
Isis for that matter but then again is
been killing Muslims in in their land no
but it wouldn't seem to to be the the
timing for it now cuz all Muslim all
Muslims are focusing on Palestine now
exactly bro and these bro man and Isis
is the one that's firstly they're
condemning Hamas they're killing Muslims
more Muslims are killed than non-muslims
by ISIS and they they always seem to be
attacking the enemies of Israel and
never Israel which is perplexing and and
very convenient well that's all we have
to say BR sisters I hope you guys I
don't know what your takes on it put in
the comment section but uh you know our
take on this matter I think it's there's
something really weird and Sinister
going on till next time
sisters